okay let's let's let's go into identity
this is very important because in in
sanskrit the word Omkara is very
interesting the ego or egoism and so the
ideas that do you identify with the ego
do you identify with the the limited
finite self in this body and nothing
else or do you identify your self as
universal as transcendent and there's a
huge difference between those and also
we can call something like an awakening
awakenings or enlightenment or the so
this the process whether it be gradually
or suddenly to feeling universal or and
transcendent the process that we all are
aiming to pierce that veil and science
does I would like to hear your take on
the science does a very interesting job
at revealing the unity and the
interconnectedness and I and I would
love to see more spiritualists embody
some of these scientific understandings
of unity because I think that would help
with the synthesis but also scientists
themselves like in 1945 if they were
more spiritually awake they wouldn't
have dropped bombs on Hiroshima Nagasaki
so there's that other side as well
scientists can also gain a decent amount
of spiritual knowledge the general idea
is this
you cannot inside spoon this you cannot
you take 20,000 breaths of air every
single day you can't live without oxygen
but you can't take one of those 20,000
breaths without summoning the
photosynthesis that is happening from
phytoplankton and trees around the
planet so you are deeply interconnected
with the oxygen cycle of the planet with
photosynthesis and so a question is
something to ask oneself is do I what
where where do I draw a line or like a
a boundary when when do I say that I am
NOT the phytoplankton and the trees that
provide me with oxygen all of these the
approximation is 25 sextillion which is
10 with 21 zeros after it
oxygen molecules that I am inhaling
every breath every breath and then those
are oxygenating my body where do I draw
the line I have I have a thousand we we
all each have a thousand species of
bacteria in our gut microbiome so do you
affiliate yourself with the one thousand
species of gut bacteria and how they
have two million total genes versus you
have twenty thousand genes so a hundred
times more genetic expression happening
from those from those gut microbial
another example is when do you when do
you take if you take the Apple or the
banana and when you when do you become
when does the apple or banana become you
when you when you bite it and you begin
chewing it when it actually becomes
digested and you go through the process
of cellular respiration and the
adenosine triphosphate powers you and
energizes you so this is these are the
things that science literally proves
interconnectedness and unity and I'm
curious what do you think about the
scientific angle and how it can help the
spiritual angle of non-duality flourish
so and you you've just demonstrated from
a physical point of view the that we as
individual people or we as a as a as a
body are intimately connected with the
universe in fact not even not even
intimately connected we are not even
apart from the universe as a
independently existing entity either to
be connected with it all or not
connected with it there there is no
clear
distinction even from a physical point
of view which is the point of view
you've just demonstrated and which as
you say quite rightly science makes very
clear it is an arbitrary line but the
the non-dual understanding goes much
further than this it doesn't presume to
begin with that what we essentially are
is a body whether or not we are
intimately connected to the universe the
non dual understanding first and the
non-dual approach makes this deep
investigation into what we essentially
are not most of us most people believe
and feel that what they essentially are
is is a body which has generated
consciousness inside it in particular
inside the brain and that the body as
such sorry that consciousness as such is
born or appears when the body appears
that it evolves as the body involves and
that it dies or disappear disappears
when there when the body disappears in
other words the consciousness shares the
limits and the destiny of the body this
is the standard approach in in our
culture and even from this approach what
you have just demonstrated the
interconnectedness of of us this
apparent body this body it is absolutely
true then on your approach as I said
goes must be but it first of all
investigates what we essentially are and
it trained in this investigation we
trace back our experience of ourselves
discarding everything that is not
essential to us our thoughts are
obviously not essential to us they are
always appearing and disappearing our
feelings likewise sensations perceptions
activities relationships these are all
elements of experience that are added to
us they remain for a while and then they
leave us but what is the us what is the
essential irreducible element of
ourselves
and if we if we undergo this experiment
and it's a very simple experiment
anybody can do it we end up with just a
simple being our simple self-aware being
it's like it's like undressing at night
when we go to bed at night we we take
off all the layers of clothes each layer
is of course superfluous to us that
clothes are changing all the time and we
get to our naked bodies that that
element of ourselves relatively speaking
that cannot be removed that is our naked
being well if we do the same thing
relative to our experience and we take
off so to speak our thoughts feelings
memories sensations perceptions
activities and relationships we end up
with pure awareness and this is a pure
self-aware being so this is the first
great discovery and that's what we share
is that just the first step is the
discovery I am awareness this is not yet
what is referred to as enlightenment or
awakening in the traditions then the
next step is to investigate the nature
of the review so we took off all of the
layers of identity and then we got to
the most primal the most first rinse
appalled which was the awareness yes we
took off everything that we were
identified with everything that we
thought was essential to us thoughts
feelings etc and we got back to our own
naked identity our original our original
face as they say in the the the Zen
tradition the the essential nature of
the mind as they say in in Buddhism the
self as they say in the in the Hindu
tradition so that's the first discovery
I am what I essentially am is simply the
fact of being aware or awareness itself
the next discovery is is to discover the
nature of the awareness that I am too
the discovery that it is ever-present
that it has no limits and that its
nature is it is inherently peaceful and
unconditionally fulfilled and that this
is the ranking that is traditionally
referred to is enlightenment so that I
would say this was that the second
recognition happiness is my nature yes
the third great recognition the
meditation is not something that we do
it's what we are we are the happiness
the Bliss the unity yes the essential
nature of the awareness that I am is
peace or happiness
yes and then the third we can come back
and just yes
the third great recognition which you
hinted at the the recognition that the
beating that we essentially are is
shared by not only everyone but
everything in other words everyone and
everything derive their apparently
independent existence from a single
infinite and indivisible reality or
whole whose nature is well ultimately it
is unnameable because all names have
evolved to describe the content of
experience but if we are going to speak
about these matters that's given a
provisional name in in these circles we
tend to speak of it as consciousness or
awareness in religious circles it is
referred to as God's presence or Brahman
but in common parlance it is referred to
as I myself my being the the one
infinite and indivisible reality which
doesn't connect us all because in the
ultimate analysis there is no all there
there is not a multiplicity and
diversity of objects themselves each
with their own independent existence to
be connected in the ultimate analysis
there are no independently existing
objects or so there is simply
single infinite indivisible whole which
is refracted through the prism of the
finite mind and appears as many things
and many people so as a concession to
the belief that there are many things
and many people we can say that we all
share our reality but in the earth if we
will really want to be try to be more
accurate in the ultimate reality that
there is no we there are no separate
objects ourselves either to be united or
not to be united there is simply the
unity of being that appears and as this
multiplicity and diversity and and the
recognition where we are speaking of
this in in intellectual terms and
analyzing it with the use of a rational
mind but the recognition that we share
our being is a familiar recognition that
millions of people I would suggest that
everybody has some taste of and that is
the experience of love love is the
recognition that we share our be yeah
yeah yeah there's several things there
there's the you mentioned the the doubt
that can be named is not the eternal Dao
there's also a hot dog whoa dude which
is that the unity of all being the unity
of all existence so this is it's also
interesting it's such a perennial wisdom
it's literally across all of these
ancient spiritual traditions across the
planet of course it is because it's
what's true because it's fun what's
really anyone at anytime irrespective of
their location on the earth that the
time in which they have been built
anyone that goes to the nature of
reality by definition goes to the same
reality because reality is always the
same thing which is not a thing so of
course all these diverse expressions of
truth or reality are going to point to
the in their own unique ways are going
to point ultimately to
same reality because reality is always
real it is always the same it doesn't
reality is not one thing in India and
another thing in America it's not one
thing in 2000 years ago and another
thing today reality is and in 2,000
years time reality will be exactly what
it is now although if human beings still
exist then they will express it in very
very different ways the language we're
speaking will seem so arcade to and we
cannot imagine what that language will
be yeah yeah and we in in the way that
science also aims to approach this and
validate this is through this unbroken
chain of evolution to that source point
and even the way of perceiving it that
way and all of these other ways in terms
of trying to pierce the veil of where is
this boundary and at least the slow
process of getting beyond the veil of
the ego to the universal to the
transcendent to the unity of all
existence is there's so many of these
different ways up this mountain to that
nature of reality but like you say at
that pinnacle point at that nature of
reality the ultimate point is that
infinite consciousness and I think this
is a very interesting way to put it is
there is this ultimate point so this
kind of leads me into the next point